no secret that public schools especially
I mean in Miami here like you know
especially High School not exactly um
the best play right there but why do you
choose homeschooling over private school
like Pat has done a very very hardcore
vetting process so if you Biz DOC for
the types of schools he wants his kids
to go to right Pat I mean you you've
gone through this process and you've
chosen the best of the best private
schools because a you can afford it but
B because they teach the values and
principles that you want your kids
learning for sure what made you go down
the homeschool path rather than the
private school well I I grew up
Minnesota I had friends who are doing it
all right buddies that they got kids
they got married in their 20s I got
married in my 30s so there's a whole
different Road for me but they were
homeschooling their kids and so there's
a lot of questions I had about that as
well and I saw the way their kids turned
out the kids are awesome and they're
great with adults they're great with you
know they don't have to go through the
ridiculous bullying and the whole click
thing and stuff like that and they're
awesome with everybody and I see that
with my kids as well
um my wife just said my oldest time was
in second grade and we thought we were
in a better school district because we
were out of L.A County we're up in
Ventura county in California we're
supposed to be you know more
conservative more better same problems
in those schools as well my wife said
enough of this she goes I'm going to
dive into this and she talked to the
friends that I knew that we're
homeschooling and she just went for it
full on and she is like a hardcore
homeschool Advocate travels a country
this is one of her books right there on
it and um she speaks across the country
constantly on it and actually she's
speaking at Mar-A-Lago this this weekend
about homeschooling there too is there
like Obama putting an event over there
or at mar-lago uh not Obama's not now I
thought maybe he probably won't be there
but anyway just curious um I'd love to
tell you my meeting with him one time
um but Obama oh yeah but um it was it
was it was just something that for us
worked really well and also for the
travel that we did with it it just it
just made more sense and one thing one
blessing of covet you mentioned with one
thing about covet
um people started waking up to see how
horrible our school system is because it
sucks I don't know what we rank
worldwide the 27th in the world it's
something pretty bad right now and
um
when when uh we we dove into this we
were just happy to be part of it covet
good Lord two million more kids now are
being homeschooled because people said
enough of this enough using public
schools as a babysitting service for our
kids look what's going on in our schools
and then you know the whole Mass wearing
of kids too that just cracked me up and
fouchy did you see what he said somebody
asked him about do you know the origin
of this now can we finally figure that
out and then they asked oh he wouldn't
talk about that then they asked him out
the mask wearing thing and he said I'm
not here to cover such trivialities I'm
here to say people's lives okay yes
that's what you're for the greatest war
criminal probably ever in the history of
America but that's another story and he
came back and he admitted that there is
a deleterious effect on the nation's
kids because of the lockdown in terms of
the educational development that
happened there and so he came out and
said it but then he said but don't blame
me for it it's not my fault it's like
come on dude come on dude yeah y'all
want amnesty I don't think history is
going to favor the that guy very well
because no it's just not going to happen
with that guy there's going to be
eventually a movie we're going to watch
and you're going to sit there and say
wow what a dirty guy I think a lot of
people are going to say that about him
they're trying to protect him because he
helped them get rid of somebody in
office that none of them liked and uh
the swamp didn't like party your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
thank you
[Music]